This is the reason I'm having a problem
you. You're drunk. Cuz you're a drunk and you're [__]
wasted coming on the stream and you're not LISTENING TO
UH OKAY, THAT CAN'T BE THE CRASH SHOW, RIGHT? It's got to be
way worse than that cuz that's just funny.
Do you want to take Do you want to take a look and see what Pisco's
saying?
We can hear you just fine. Yeah, you're you're clear. Yeah, I
think the most important thing is what happens now. I think that's
going to be the Okay, I'm waiting for Lacto to join cuz that's
when it will actually get interesting.
That's somebody capable of forming coherent sentences who disagrees
with Pisco. Very interested in that. >> international or
US law to challenge this and the reason I bring this up
as the USA lost all moral authority to sanction Russian oil.
Um I mean they probably didn't have moral Realistically, whenever
you have this conversation, it's like realistically the US never
had moral authority. They only have moral authority to Americans,
which is probably the only moral authority they care about, right?
It's essentially like do you care about
Yeah, do you do you care about um the US saying we're doing this
to sanction somebody who's been a bad like a bad actor?
It's about Americans' view of it.
The rest of the world pretty much usually knows that Ameri- America
doesn't really have the moral authority
in general.
Stop is the foundation of every legal system. It's someone making
some claim, someone maybe defending it, and someone else making
a decision about it. It's just structurally how it works. So,
I'm I'm not even challenging you whether they could enforce it,
right? We have international courts that say things like Benjamin
Netanyahu is a terrorist and yet nothing happens. So, let's
It's a bit of an L take.
Okay, why did America have the moral authority to do anything?
Why is America a moral authority?
Why why do they have a moral authority
Read above. They're permanent UN Security Council member. They
have a mandate to take leadership like the UK and France. Yeah,
they do, but they've never They've literally never submitted
to any of the rules-based international
America has standing policy if any American is ever indicted
on war crimes to invade The Hague.
When have they ever had the moral authority to dictate how other
countries should act? They dictate how other countries should
act because they have the economic might and the military might
to do so. But it's not It's not really based on like
there's a veneer of moral authority there, but it's like I I
think it's just a veneer. I I think they should follow it because
as you continue to follow it, it becomes better and better like
it becomes more and more of like you are a moral authority, right?
But it if it just It's not really the truth. It's not really
Like the Ukraine thing, people like oh, they have the moral authority
because Ukraine's in the right. The US doesn't support Ukraine
cuz they're in the right. That's not why they made that decision.
that part, but just what court would we go to and what would
we say?
I think it's important personally cuz it's something everybody
can believe in, but at this point I don't think um
Yeah, I just I think it's gone. I think it's gone. So so so your
question is unclear cuz there's two different formulations of
it. One I'm I'm I I
So so I just want to be clear about where I stand on the two
different formulations. Right right So, I want to be clear about
the two different formulations. So, the first question you asked
was which court with enforcement authority would be able to adjudicate
this as against the United States? >> No, I'm saying please
stop talking about it. So so so wait hang on a Please stop I
engaged with your hypothetical engaged with Wait wait wait no
I don't So, I So so so the reason why I'm asking these questions
is because I don't understand which question you're asking. Are
you asking which court from the perspective of with enforcement
authority or you're asking which court could someone go to to
adjudicate this?
The second question. Okay, the ICJ. Have you heard of it?
Yes. Okay, so you're you are allowed to to adjudicate state-based
claims in the ICJ. Don't we have a Hague law? Don't we have a
Hague law? Like if we Hold on. So, you agree with the Hague law?
If we Hold on. If the I If I see uh-oh. If the US soldier for
anything that they did under the orders of the US president it's
unconstitutional and illegal for us not to invade The Hague.
Would it not be that that not true? Never do I fear terror like
when Admiral Gibbs picks up the the opinion I just had
and starts appearing to agree with it. Never have I felt more
terror. And put them over there in trial. Then you see Pisco
useless. Oh, sure. That's not what he asked either. This is This
is exactly why WAIT WAIT WAIT GIBBS PISCO OKAY, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Why? I'm just clarifying cuz of bad faith hacks
like you might
Well, hold on. I'm just asking you because you know, you're lawyer
Lacto's lawyer if any international court put tried to try a
US soldier for anything that they did under the orders of the
US president, it's unconstitutional
and illegal for us not to invade The Hague. Would it not be that
that not true?
I don't know your what your the answer is to your question. It
would it be illegal or unconstitutional to invade The Hague?
I don't I I guess I haven't
I don't know about that.
I I don't I don't I didn't Did you hear me say the ICJ would
So, I'm not sure. I haven't analyzed whether it would be illegal.
I assume it would be illegal under international law to invade
The Hague or anything like that. We're talking about US law.
That's what you just talked about. Let's just translate a little
bit here. Just The Hague is in the Netherlands. Yes. What Pisco's
claiming is that uh we have a duty as a country if an international
court such as The Hague mm
Wait, it depends on what they were being indicted on.
Uh I I feel like
You say that I I feel like they would do it on certain people
depending on who they are.
They might They might chill on a soldier who'd like explicit
war crimes like somebody who'd been like kids. It would just
come down to
If it's anybody who's even remotely defensible, I do think they'd
say no, you have to give us that person or we are going to go
posture over here. It'd probably be a situation where I think
The Hague would blink. tried to try one of our soldiers uh for
carrying That's not what's being proposed. Hang on. Hang on.
So so the reason why it's irrelevant is no one proposed a criminal
trial. Wait I'm going to Gibbs, you just said it's pretty relevant.
I'm going to We're now going to stick on the relevance issue
and I'm going to show you why it's irrelevant. Did you hear him
ask? Wait, okay. So, did Did you hear this with the beard uh
Streamr if Did you hear him ask where we would try Americans
and individuals? Did you hear him ask that? It'll be in the US
cuz it won't be in the Hague. That's why we all have beards.
Hang on a second. Did you
This is This is a very simple answer you can give. Did you hear
Streamr if ask where we would try individuals
It would be in the US. I'm sure No no no it's just the No no
the question isn't would it be this or that. I'm asking Did you
hear? This is a question about your sensory I heard it and that's
why I asked that question. See, you actually didn't hear him
ask what whether or not this uh Did you hear me ask that question?
Um basically the the president has all authorization. There is
no limit on their power to go and pursue somebody who's being
tried at The Hague, but they can let it go. They can just let
it go. They're not
your question is presupposing criminal trials of individuals,
which was not captured in his question. So, of course it's irrelevant
because his question His
No no his question pertained only to whether or not there could
or there there does exist international tribunals to
international law issues between states and there are such tribunals.
Now, America hasn't uh you know, ratified or signed on.
No, so here's the thing. I brought up You might as well get You
might as well kick Gibbs out. This is such a derail. Go. I I
am not I'm not I'm not No one
So so No one is talking No one I'll I'll take I'll take Gibbs.
Shut up. Right? Okay, good. Excellent. We can't do this if we're
all trying to talk at once and all going in different directions
at once. Pisco wants to talk about the legality when it comes
to the US Constitution.
So, let's No no that's not what he was talking ABOUT. WAIT, HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THESE OTHER NO STOP STOP for the moment. Let's
stick to that and then we can move on to other portions. For
the moment I was trying to do that Wiki.
This is the reason I'm having a problem with you. Cuz you're
drunk. Cuz you're a drunk and you're [__] wasted
coming on the stream and you're not LISTENING TO PEOPLE.
OKAY, THAT CAN'T BE THE CRASH SHOW, RIGHT? It's got to be way
worse than that cuz that's just funny.
Let me let me I'm not drunk or wasted yet. I haven't done any
drugs. Okay, you guys both I'm going to mute you both if if I
if you
I'm not drunk yet. Okay. Let me let me be clear. Okay? We are
at this point in time talking about whether or not it is legal.
We can get to the morality of it later and I think that that
will be an interesting discussion, but do we think currently
that it is legal
what Trump did with the strikes? That's a good question to start
with. Who Just raise your hand if you think it was legal under
the US constitutional law.
So, we got two
Yeah, this is the problem. Is anybody who's raising their hand
when Trump does something that a lot of people are saying is
illegal, it's obviously not going to be clear that it is legal
or illegal, right? Like clearly not. Obviously not.
And one guy without hands, right? So, we don't know. But okay.
I would say no. Okay, so it's It's going to be arguable. It's
just going to be arguable. Did Gibbs just take a shot from a
huge bottle? I think that was literally water. Or wait, what
was in there? Doesn't look like water. It's like a 7-Eleven cup
or something. Got two and a half.
And one guy without hands, right? Uh so, we don't know. But okay.
I would say no. Okay, so
The only reason I brought this up Yes. Wait, does this guy literally
not have hands? When he said doesn't have hands, no, he put an
arm up, right? He put an arm up. No, he has hands. For a second
I was like, dude, does he literally not have He does have hands.
You you you might as well get You might as well kick Gibbs out.
This is such a deal. Oh, sorry. Sorry. Let's
Cuz you're drunk. Cuz you're a drunk and you're wasted coming
on the stream and you're not listening to people. Let me Let
me
Okay. Uh so, we don't know. But okay. I would say no. Okay, so
You asked. So, like that's like if we can talk about who's talking
about I was in an accident court, none of that actually is relevant.
What is relevant is what would happen here in the US. So, you're
talking about international court? Is cuz stream asked He asked
me whether or not there are international tribunals to adjudicate
claims as
Yeah the the thought unfortunately wasn't being expanded because
the question wasn't wasn't wasn't specific to the criminal it
wasn't specific to two things. A, either criminal trials Your
quote. Can I explain it? wasn't No. No. No. I'm going to finish
No, sorry. Sorry. I'm I'm going to explain why I'm going to explain
why this derail is a derail. So, the question that stream whatever
rift asked wasn't A, specific to criminal tribunals and B, to
individuals. He was merely asking the question of like where
international law disputes can be adjudicated. Are there such
international bodies? And I listed one such body. There are other
bodies as well that relate to other kinds of spheres of domain
expertise, but that's just one place. Now, I suspect
as I predicted, the argu
That's kind of debate perversion, isn't Um I didn't think you
you just asked if it's possible to litigate one of these things
and where you possibly could. You didn't ask if you could litigate
it there for this issue. You just asked if like possibly there's
something. You didn't ask me about how it would go. You didn't
ask me if like enforcement would be possible. You just asked
me about if you could like raise a complaint. I feel like that's
kind of debate perversion. How much longer? Well, how can they
enforce it? That of course is irrelevant to the question about
whether or not international law exists.
So, let's assume that we're at the ICJ and as Gibbs point
Wait, he he was saying that was the question, but I'm saying
that like if somebody asked me that question, did he Maybe he
clarified and said purely, can you raise this somewhere? Is it
But like that's the is it possible, right? It's like a total
waste of time to just answer that question. Somebody Usually
people won't ask that question if that's all you're doing, right?
Like like I don't I'm not going to ask you if it's possible to
do something that like there's obviously an outside chance that
you could do it. Very silly. pointed out, American soldiers get
a free pass. So, when American soldiers go out and conquer wherever
the [__] they want, any court in that you're talking
about says, "Oh, they're flying the red, white, and blue. That's
up to the red, white, and blue. And if they're doing what the
red, white, and blue did Listen, maybe I just didn't Yeah, maybe
I just wasn't following that closely. Sorry, I'm trying to get
like uh more situated. I started the stream cuz I was late already
and I wasn't sitting down. I just went and got some caffeine,
so maybe I maybe I just missed it. >> a free pass. So,
is there another court that might act cuz Yeah, this is this
is the problem, right? So so just just just to be So so okay,
yeah. I wasn't I wasn't involved in listening. So, you're asking
so I was correct when I interrupted you when you were asking
the questions about the court that your question is specific
Wait, did we all even see that or did I just skip right past
it? I might have skipped right past it. >> Your question
was specific to courts that have enforcement a power that that
actually have the ability to enforce their judgments. And my
answer my answer my answer Oh, you guys are giving me contexts
I didn't have and I'm like, oh, I guess I just missed it. And
nobody says anything. You guys just all watched this already.
And you're like filling in things I didn't see. Like, oh, how
could you possibly not understand what I don't understand. My
answer to that is as against the United States, there is no such
international body. But that's just a descriptive claim and it
doesn't mean that international law doesn't exist and it doesn't
mean that we shouldn't hue to these other principles. And I'll
have you know
Yes, law can exist even if there is nobody to enforce it. They're
not contradictory at all. Law does not presuppose
some enforcement apparatus. Okay, what's the contradiction?
But the contradiction is if you can't enforce it, then the law
doesn't exist. Like that like that's that's how that
Hey. Hey. That's restating the claim. So so so just just what
this drunk just said what this drunk just said is So, I asked
HIM THE QUESTION
DUDE. SOMEBODY TOLD ME PISCO WAS LIKE crashing out. This is just
funny. This is like content.
I'll wait until he gets like way over the line or way crazy about
it, but this is just funny as This is way better. Normally he's
like cringe when he's angry. This is just
I'm sorry, this is funny. Up until this point it's funny. Wait.
WAIT. I I ASKED him the question. Wait. Wait. So, Gibbs I asked
him the question. Wait. Wait. I I just want to explain I know
I just want to explain what you what you just what you just said.
Hold on. Let Pisco go and then Gibbs can respond. Both of you
won't interrupt each other. So, Pisco go uninterrupted. So, I
asked Gibbs.
I asked Gibbs. I said, "Well, um what's the justification for
the claim that law can't exist without an adjudicatory body to
enforce the law?" And he said, "Well, of course it can't because
you can't have law without an adjudicatory body."
Is Pisco going to be um example US Congress?
Is that what he's going to say?
Example US Congress. Example separation of powers. Example like
the founders of your country believed that the ability to craft
laws and the ability to enforce laws should be separated and
handled by different bodies.
Is that Wouldn't that be the example you'd use? Like they're
arguing you can't have enforcement separated from like from crafting
and having laws exist and that is literally the case. body that
can enforce it. It's exactly circular. I didn't ask you to repeat
the claim. I asked you to justify
>> Oh, well, okay, cool. Can I answer now? Well, so since
I'm a drunk and I and I guess, you know, I I I there's a cool
show on the History Channel and and I think it was on Comedy
Central cute it's called Drunk History. So, I guess we're going
to do some drunk history real quick and teach teach Pisco something
cuz clearly he studied a lot of law, didn't study very much history.
I don't know if you've heard of this place called the Bahamas
and specifically Nassau. But the British owned that and they
had laws. And guess what happened? It became what they called
the Pirate Republic where there was really no laws. It's maybe
arguably one of the only times in history where we had a true
like representative republic. Pirates were big on that. They
didn't do the laws. They just had their own system of government.
They disobeyed the British. And why was that? Because they had
enough power to do what they wanted and the British couldn't
do squat about it. And they had to ask the Spanish to help them
take them out. Thanks for the history lesson, Professor. Yeah,
it's relevant. I I didn't interrupt you. I didn't interrupt you.
Listen, that's just rude. That's just rude. If we're going to
be interrupting, I'm down to be interrupting. But uh you don't
Like nobody doubts this. The entire purpose of having laws is
that you want people to follow the rules and not just treat it
as might makes right all the time. That you give some some people
like a sense of fairness. You give them a reason to invest in
the game and play by the rules instead of just doing whatever
they they want hoping you don't come down and and like destroy
their
You give people a set of rules. You want them to follow it. You
you don't like
You get people to enfor or to follow the rules and and that's
like supposed to be a better world. That's the whole thing. We're
committed to this better world where we all follow the rules.
Pisco will respond. We'll hear from
Well, also, prior to the rules-based international order, people
didn't follow it. Also, little history lesson.
Can you point to me where the Pirate Republic exists on the map
today?
It seems like not joining what was There was sort of an international
rules-based order, but it was much more like do what the English
government tells you, okay? But what happened to Nassau?
As far as I know, that [__] got wrecked. [__]
My point is this and this is the point that I made when I was
trying to make the stream rift was going is that might makes
right. You know, y'all said y'all had this joke about this earlier
or whatever. But in the United States, we have a lot of super
powers. We're the most powerful country in the world. We have
the ASPA. We have 2002. They basically said if you try to put
US soldiers on trial, we're going to come and whoop that ass.
So, we don't recognize international law. And when we do, we
only recognize it when it's convenient to us. So, when it comes
to whether they're going to have this trial. If they were, it's
going to be in the US. And since we've expanded the powers at
since which I'm sure Lakoy can go into since Bush, guess what?
These soldiers, none of them going to be tried. So, guess what?
As long as it's not constitutionally illegal, which I guess is
the debate, then guess what? There's no international body that
we have to worry about. Because guess what? We're not definitely
WE'RE NOT THE THAT PISCO wants us to be. Okay. So so you you
see what happens, right? So, the the people I see you
The people defending this action are literally the lowest common
denominator. They cannot follow the argument. The question wasn't
to give a ramble about history and the inevitability of, you
know, the futility of other bodies trying to enforce law as against
the
Dude. Dude. Dude. And it states
the land of the free since 1776.
>> Which I readily exceed is just true by virtue of the
fact that America's the strongest country and no other country's
going to be able boss us around. That wasn't Came in late. Who's
the caveman trying to Pisco? This is Admiral Gibbs. Infamous
Tim Pool participant Admiral Gibbs, okay?
He just gave us a whole thing. He basically just said might makes
right and the US is mighty.
That's that's his winning argument, okay? We get to do whatever
we want. Fascism is awesome is his argument, okay? Very cool.
The question was whether or not law entails some kind of enforcement
mechanism and you failed fundamentally
to just you failed fundamentally to go and interrupt. Yeah, that's
what that's the claim I'm By the way, I'm guessing that the pirates
had like a what do you call it? I'm guessing that even under
his pirate
isn't that wouldn't they have laws as pirates? Wouldn't there
be like a a codex of laws that they would follow? And then if
you didn't follow that like there wouldn't be an explicit for
explicit enforcement arm, they would
basically make a militia as required. I'm asking you to justify,
not to repeat. Not to repeat. Let me let me just do let's just
do a six No, not the pirate code from the movies. There was something
like that though. They were it was like an idea. Some of those
people were educated. They were thinking they they called themselves
a republic. They thought they had like a they were they were
like an anarchic state. They would have had rules, man. Not like
movies though. Well, actually probably like the movies. It probably
was very much like the movies unironically. Not Pirates of the
Caribbean though. If I walk up to you, I don't know, Streamer,
and I come over here and I decide I'm going to put some baby
powder around my hand and I'm going to beat the crap out of him
and then I'm going to stab him 52 times in GTA, all right? Guess
what's going to happen? If there's law, someone's going to come
and enforce that crime. Putting Pirates of the Caribbean in my
chat. Stop. I'm going to ban people who quote Pirates of the
Caribbean in my chat. Stop doing it. Right? Right? Someone's
going to have to enforce that. Now, if there's no power to enforce
that, then I'm going to go over here to Lactoid and be like,
I don't like HIS BEARD. BANG BANG BANG BANG BANG. AND GUESS WHAT?
NOW THERE'S TWO PEOPLE DOWN. AND GUESS WHAT? If there's nobody
to enforce IT, I CAN MAKE all the laws in the world. It doesn't
[__] matter. Just like the Hittites, they can make
all these laws, but if they can't enforce it, they mean [__]
diddly squat. So so just a a real quick
Wait wait wait just just a real quick question. If someone grabbed
and graped your mother, let's say, in some island and then the
the the perpet-
LET'S GO. PISCO has figured out the rape analogy. All right,
very powerful weapon. Can he utilize it correctly? died and guess
what? Evidence is
Did that person Did that person violate the law? Yes or no?
Well, if they don't get I don't know. Oh, that's actually He
didn't have to use rape, but that is actually the best example,
isn't it? You literally break the law and then die. You literally
can't have the law enforced on you. Was the law broken?
Yeah, they did violate the law. Yeah yeah, they did by graping
your mother and and the fact the fact but last last word will
go to Lactoid. Last word. The fact that you won't grant that
hypothetical shows how bad faith you are. Oh yeah, because it's
because I'm not a dumbass like you are. Lactoid Lactoid, you
have some thoughts.
Uh Pisco, so there's no reason to talk to Don't bring a rape
analogy unless you're going to go hardcore with it. He should
have said I would and as much as we all
He should have made a joke, okay? I think you could sneak in.
Listen, was your mother raped? The real question isn't whether
your mother was raped or whether it broke the law. The real question
is whether it was a rape law or law, Gibbs. That's the real [__]
>> What's up? Can you hear me okay? Yeah, what's up? Yeah,
I just joined in. I It's a It's a Pisco's in the panel and it's
aggressive. I I don't know what happened. Um yeah, so I I guess
I don't really know exactly where we're in. I kind of jumped
in and people were screaming. So I guess what's the broad question
here? >> The question is whether or not you would support
if it could be shown that the actions that Trump took were illegal
via or unconstitutional, I should say, via US law, right? Would
you still support it? Yes or no?
Unconstitutional via US law, I would not because my loyalty is
to America.
But international law,
I mean we break that [__] all the time. Everyone
kind of does. I We deserve deference to it. Like I'm not saying
it's not worth nothing, but I mean we broke international law
and
I'm not saying it's not worth nothing.
Nicky, you're a lawyer. Kosovo
Ukrainians did when they cluster bombed the Donbass. Russia did
when they invaded Ukraine. I mean this just happens all the [__]
time. So personally, I don't really have loyalty to the international
community. Like I don't really care. Violations of US law happen
all the time and the US Constitution happen all the time.
No, I understand. It happens, but what I'm saying is like my
loyalty is to the US Constitution and not like the international
community at large. The reason why I start there and why frankly
I I think that we should just I don't know what Streamer is going
to do cuz Streamer has taken the I think untenable position that
even if it were unconstitutional and illegal, that he would support
the action under US law. Under US law where there are courts
of law. Now,
Yeah, no, that I mean that's crazy. It's possible that this question
could it What a what a crazy position, Lactoid.
Even if it's illegal under US law, it's unconstitutional. This
guy supports it. Yeah, I don't think I agree with him on that.
Yeah, no [__]
I assume if you want to be on here, you have a US flag hanging
in your background, you probably go, I like the Constitution.
That should probably be your general vibe. I like the Constitution.
I like US law. >> could be illegal and non-justiciable
under US law. Just putting it out there. Just because a court
can't resolve it again doesn't mean that it's not illegal. There
are certain powers that are entrusted only to particular branches
which other courts can't resolve. Doesn't mean there isn't some
notion of illegality. But yeah, I I think that we should start
there. I think that Wick's instinct is correct. If we resolve
the constitutional issue, at least the majority of the panel
here or the US legality issue will be against the strikes.
So and that's the difficulty though. So this just happened last
night, right? I woke up and I saw this and I was like, what the
[__] Holy [__] So I haven't done a deep
dive into kind of the the history of I understand that this was
applied somewhat in Panama. There is some precedent here as to
how US
Oh, yeah. Hello? Is that me? Okay,
And it might go out again. My other headset actually I've got
two of the same headsets. My other one actually broke and so
I used my backup and now this one's breaking. So the gods are
unfavorable to me tonight.
Panama, there was some historic So US courts ruled that even
if a defendant comes into the US unwillingly, whether it be like
through some kind of like abduction by US forces, that you could
like if this is still like legal, like you can still prosecute
them. Um I understand that the current administration's just
to be different. That That's whether the court has jurisdiction
of you jurisdiction
That's Yeah, I think the issue is they're trying to decide whether
or not the administration's action in like striking Venezuela,
doing a conducting an operation on foreign soil in this obviously
this like clear and obvious way that they attribute to themselves.
Right? Is that legal under the the exact like rationale they
gave? of you for your criminal
trial when you're when you're in the United States, but that
is not ruling on the legality of the abduction itself.
Well, sure, but I'm getting there. Like I said, this just happened
last night. I've I've had a couple hours here.
So that's in terms of they're here now. Now you know, they they're
under US jurisdiction. My understanding is that the legal justification
for the abduction itself was under Article 2, President has powers
to enforce the law and because
Maduro
is not the legal head of state according to the US,
that he was essentially just an international criminal that was
apprehended by US forces and then brought to the US.
Yeah, this is the argument.
In my opinion, to be honest, like he did steal that election,
right? Like there is overwhelming evidence that Maduro is not
the legitimate head of state. No doubt to me. I hate Maduro.
I hate these tanky communist regimes.
And they should and they should.
No, no, I don't think No, no.
There's a quote Biden said, I quote, I stand with Maduro. That's
not That's not relevant right now. No one here supports Maduro.
I am you know, if there's one positive that Is that something
like
like Biden said
Dude, is that is that something Biden was saying like the exact
opposite, but it's like the quote you could cut it off and be
like >> come out of this, perhaps. I I am hoping obviously
for the best possible situation Okay, okay. It's Yeah, it's for
the Venezuelan people and I think that the you know, that option
isn't possible so long as Maduro or people who are his ideological
sympathizers are in power. So that I'm hoping is a is a but that
again doesn't justify any action. It needs to be addressed on
its own terms. So with respect to the claim of US authority to
seize and abscond with individuals without the consent of the
host nation. Um and that clearly I think that that that it would
need to be derived from Article 2. But the but the question is
why do we think that that's derived from Article 2? It proves
too much. If there were inherent Article 2 authorities to just
enforce the law, what is the limiting principle there? Congress
couldn't by virtue of its legislation therefore pass laws to
limit the ability of law enforcement to do all sorts of things,
right? Like what would be the limits on executive enforcement
when we're reading into this like very very broad, so broad by
the way, that it would have to be read to negate
customary
or international law or the rule of nations,
which regardless of whether or not you individually think that
matters, to think that the frameworks we're setting up a system
by which the president unilaterally
can bypass those things through some unspecified
portion of the of article two. I think I think it's it's not
clear at all. And maybe you could say pursuant to the rule of
nations or sorry the war of the rule of war and the the laws
of nations you could the president has certain inherent authorities.
That I would accept but that would presuppose you acting in conformity
with the law of nations. And so to the extent that there is inherent
powers I don't think that we should be read them
I wish could he reframe that in the form of like talking about
Admiral Gibbs' mother? Could I I didn't understand it. I feel
like it was a little windy or little long-winded. Could he reframe
that and reformulate that in terms of Admiral Gibbs' mother?
Who is Admiral Gibbs' mom in what way? Pisco I I'm I'm losing
it. He had me before he's lost me now okay?
violating those customary rules.
I I don't know about that. So well let me just elaborate a little
bit.
So the president has authority to enforce the law right? They
they they have this they're the executive they have the they
they this ability. In Iraq for example we blew up al-Baghdadi.
I don't recall I don't think we asked the Iraqis permission for
that and the argument was not like was because this is not a
legitimate state actor. This is just essentially some kind of
international terrorist. This is some kind of like international
criminal. If we're talking about state actors If we're talking
about state actors I agree it gets a little bit fuzzy
US the US legal issue in the case of Iraq there was congressional
authorization which obviates the concerns
that we're talking about. For oh sorry for Baghdadi specifically.
Yeah for Baghdadi no no yes yes there is. There there is the
the war resolution against the al-Qaeda and related terrorist
groups. That which wouldn't apply to Venezuela. >> Oh oh
so the thing I was talking about earlier when you said it was
irrelevant. No what was irrelevant what was irrelevant from you
was the history lesson professor.
Well yeah because the reason why the history lesson was RELEVANT
IS BECAUSE
YEAH SO I I guess this is my understanding is there was a 2003
bill
If he's not drunk he should get drunk okay? So that kind of granted
the president a broad discretion when it comes to these kind
of specific actions against like terrorists or you know after
9/11 we gave the president a whole lot of power. And Maduro is
um you know alleged to be essentially be a narco-terrorist right?
I mean this is what the administration
There's no limiting principle to that interpretation. To that
interpretation. Well you're
Well the limiting principle would be you know how much um how
much authority do I mean Congress can take away their authorization
right? That that's the limiting principle. Congress has ultimately
war power lies within Congress. They have a standing grant to
the president to take unilateral action in a whole host of situations.
The Congress tomorrow if they don't like what the president is
doing they could nullify that power that they granted the president.
>> Again that's that's presupposing and begging the question.
The question is did they grant it in the first instance? No doubt
you know Congress could write in legislation to purport to redact
that were at least alleged to have been given. But the whole
question is were they given or not? And I don't think you really
believe this lactoid. If America tomorrow started bombing Beijing
by virtue of the resolutions passed by Congress in response to
9/11 would you say that that was an authorized use of military
force?
Against Beijing say oh Beijing they're they're involved in fentanyl
production and so they're not You'd probably have to have escalations
right? Like that's almost certainly why Trump kept testing things
in the way he did with them blowing up boats with them declaring
them terrorists setting the bounties. Like there was a lot of
preparatory work. If Trump was escalating consistently like that
against G like that's I think that you probably get closer to
that in terms of
of like making it make sense under the same doctrines if you
are consistently taking actions as if they are terrorists and
Congress is not actually shutting you down.
But I mean that's also if you accept that I I think that's like
the argument they'll make. I don't think you can accept that
because the obvious downside there is then if you control Congress
well enough and they aren't going to step in then you can just
violate you can just do all of these things right?
So it's fine. Yeah. I hear I hear the argument. I I think bombing
a country is different than last night. No it's not. They bombed
a country. They literally bombed a country. It's not different
it's the same thing. They literally
the the broad authorization that we give the president like let's
assume that my understanding is if he was targeting like a state
actor
I don't know if that would fall under the authorization. I don't
know if that would require some kind of declaration of war.
The we're talking about like a state for like two seconds.
Oh he's got A THING.
LET HIM SUPERCHAT. GO AHEAD WICK. TO SAY am I on the Wick show
or the Pisco show? You're on the Wick show and Pisco will behave
for there will be consequences. My listening library for $5 says
almost all my favorite political streamer I mean Wick can say
that Wick's not going to kick Pisco off.
Was Wick behaving when you talked about Admiral Gibbs' mom? Sorry
was Pisco behaving not Wick. Wick didn't do that Pisco did that.
All we're missing is Prime Ky. Oh I think we're good. $10 from
Alashnitz
to say for the lawyers is the executive order designating the
drug runners as terrorists the only reason Trump can strike the
boats? I don't think I can extend to the entire country. That's
different right? The the question about the strikes the question
about the strikes is even easier. I mean that that is just so
clearly violated in my opinion of US law. Even more so than this
strike against
So yeah I I think that that one is just like very easily resolvable
under US law it's murder. I mean his actions are murder. But
but the problem I think with taking the lactoid I I guess lactoid
is not a serious Okay go for it yeah. Sure. So and this is again
part of the problem of this happening last night and me getting
up afternoon. So the when it comes to strikes on state actors
I don't know if that's broadly covered under the 2003 authorization.
I know
Yo you went out again. No. Oh no you're you're dude dude dude
actually with the is actually people that are dying to be that
No no it is NOT JUST MAYBE. YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT THAT. It's not just maybe. But like I
think the nugget of this issue though like we moved past that
now. Like we moved past And now we're like we haven't this is
it right?
Wait wait Gibbs leader of another country Gibbs this is the test
right? So we are now squarely facing the thing right? Every for
years everyone was saying oh the AUMF is being
No no no the test is
And I I it is concerning. And this is the same thing with those
like right? Like I was excited about those however I'm hesitant
because like what if someone I don't like gets in charge right?
And they start doing these things. But it's like okay if we go
and capture Maduro because he's a leader of a cartel okay foreign
guy that's fine. But if we start labeling like I don't know I'm
going to use lefty orgs because I know people on the right antifa
and we start capturing antifa leaders and like taking them back
from like places
Right so the time to take a stand against for American liberties
is now. If you're a civil libertarian you should be talking speaking
up now. Why? Because you are correct Gibbs in your
The implication is if this is truly you know a war that's being
conducted pursuant to the rule of the rules of war the laws of
war international law or you know congressional authorizations
you know related to that those things then you can target domestic
enemies right in that sense and use military force Of course
you can. In the civil war context is the civil in the civil war
context did the Bill of Rights apply? Yes or no will be the Just
no just answer the question. Did the Bill of Rights apply in
the civil war context?
What do you mean by apply? It was there but it was Apply as in
it's
The Bill of Rights absolutely
They they're like well I have to make it the same as this situation.
It it was there but it wasn't enforced. Enforcement didn't exist
cuz cuz enforcement's all that makes the law
You heard Trump say today about how we are going into Mexico
next then Cuba. Don has not forgotten about the 51st. Yeah you
can make that joke all you like. Okay soapbox
$1000
that in 2026 Trump doesn't invade Canada. You want to bet?
You can put a thousand bucks on it.
fully apply in the civil war Yes and no. So yes and no that depends
if you recognize recognize like Americans like if you consider
Confederates as Americans right? If you look at the war crimes
that were committed
From the perspective of the American government Hold on I'm trying
to ask you a question. Hold on to answer your question we have
we look at the camps they were just about the holocaust and some
of these prisoners of war for Confederates. We also look at Sherman's
march to the sea where he burned
Oh you see it as a 50/50? Perfect. Then we can have one to one
odds. Let's go. Thank you soapbox for saying it's 50/50.
So you're you'll accept one to one odds. I appreciate that.
His contention is that there could not be a legal use of military
force against enemies within the country and that's just not
true. Congress could under its authority and and the president
as well in exercising that authority could target citizens. Yes
citizens. Citizens are allowed to be combatants.
As in like literally what prevents them? If you if you accept
no you don't need any proof that these people are narco-terrorists
you just let them get bombed okay? What prevents them from saying
you are literally a member of this terrorist organization who's
about to commit a crime they kill you and then they just never
present the evidence cuz it's national security info.
Like is that not a fairly close aren't we pretty close to eroding
those two things together?
Right? They they provide no evidence for why they believe what
they do they just say this is what happened.
How if if they're allowed to do that and then they're allowed
to declare if they're allowed to declare who combatants are who
like you know
like enemy combat people they can classify as combatants are
what prevents them from declaring a citizen a
And they wouldn't do it with like a regular citizen first. They'd
probably find somebody who wasn't American citizen and was doing
some kind of terrorism that they could like make this point with.
>> Citizens are you know can be combatants under both international
law and under US law such that military force is not just justified
from an international perspective, but it's also US legal. Now,
there are Bill of Rights considerations for sure in any context,
but that didn't stop Abraham Lincoln from you know, ordering
his troops to go kill American citizens under American law. The
Bill of Rights was never suspended in the southern states. >> mind,
can I ask you a question that might be interesting? No, I want
to go back to Lactoid actually. I think your question is all
Can you Can you hear my Is this mic okay? Yeah, we can hear you
now. Unfortunately, you keep getting
Lactoid Okay, Lactoid's a lawyer.
Do we have to get Should we just raise it? Should we just ever
everybody who watches like Wick content just needs Lactoid to
get a XLR mic? Like he's on streams so often. He's on Discord
so often. In what universe do you still have headset like USB
digital headset mics in 2026?
It's crazy. There's just no reason for it to have this kind of
microphone
What are we doing here? We die with a thing anymore. Hopefully
go Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, I I guess um I don't know. >> Speaking of which,
I think my headphones might die during this Whether or not this
was legal, I'm I'm I'm kind of right now leaning towards the
fact that it is just given kind of the backdrop of
Public defender, that's why I said we should raise the money
and just get him a mic. It's like, man, why don't Why do you
Why don't you have a mic? >> one case that we had that
I have not read but just briefly like was reading when I was
doing some brief research for this was you know, involved kind
of a similar situation which military general in Panama was you
know, taken to the US not really with the permission of Panama
and you know, jurisdiction was shown. Now, I don't think I don't
know what the resolution of that was on the actual act of abducting
that leader was. Um and I don't
Uh when I bought these Moonray Murray, I literally bought them
under the understanding they could do that. These headphones
though can do two streams in a row without needing to be charged.
So, usually it's never a problem. I just forgot to charge them
before today. We'll see. They might do this stream as
Yeah, they haven't even lost like they haven't got Also, wasn't
like a former head of state now.
They exactly have just did that and they're monitoring themselves
and you're pointing that as as What? Is that proof that it's
legal because Reagan did it? Yeah, Reagan did a bunch of illegal
[__]
He arguably illegal No, I like another time. Like I said, I haven't
I haven't looked to see what the the finding of that um It's
only executive branch
You're breaking up a little bit,
of the extradition. I'm not breaking up, am I? A little bit.
But you can go. Vaguely, but we can Okay, I'm I'm What I'm talking
about I don't know what the full legality is of the extradition
in that Panama case. And I I don't know for sure.
So, it wasn't extradition. We We went in there and we got him.
I'm not I'm not talking Okay, do you want to use the word abduction?
I can use the word abduction. I'm not trying to like Yeah, yeah,
sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. I'm not trying to like fight with semantics
here. But what I abduction's fine. That's fair enough. That's
what That's what happened, right? But when it comes to the Panama
situation, I don't know if like what the ruling was in that abduction.
I don't know for sure what the ruling is going to be on the abduction
of Maduro. Uh I'm leaning towards given the broad uh powers given
to the president to conduct air strikes on terrorists to
with with evidence from that we have that we had for Al-Baghdadi.
It's absolutely tragic. supposing for Maduro uh and we're going
to see in court um just what the basis of that was. I don't think
we will. No, I don't think we will. I think what we'll see is
that the court isn't going to be there to resolve like the US
government isn't going to be on trial in the case against Maduro.
So, I don't know that we will be able to resolve this in the
courts. I'm actually like not optimistic that we will be able
to. I think the only people
No, but hang on. Let's stress test your inclination. Your inclination
is that on balance right now given the Noriega precedent, which
again I think is so ridiculous that we would like oh because
Reagan did something it's probably okay to do because he did
like Reagan also did Iran-Contra. Like Reagan did a bunch of
[__] that was illegal as well as other presidents
including Democrats and stuff. So, we shouldn't just take the
mere executive branch's oh yeah, what we're doing here is totally
above board just because we do it. I think I think he said literally
I don't know the ruling. Does anybody know the ruling? I mean,
come on. A civil libertarian can't uh What Or wait, was it even
like like adjudicated? Did they even like make a Did they even
bring it up in court like hey, this is illegal like in US court
or was it just like broadly supported when they went and grabbed
the guy out of Panama and nobody cared? It'd be like that. All
right, so let's stress test Just to be clear, Noriega was done
under Bush, not Reagan. Okay, but but Bush was there. Bush was
Bush was Bush was there He was there. He was there. He was He
was in the He He was in the room.
Wait, why was Reagan in the room? He was dementia-ridden at that
point. I'll take the L. You know what I'm talking about. And
even like logical
It's not
He's got a partisan thing, but like I want to stress test this
this inclination because I'm asking you directly, if Trump said
I'm considering Xi Jinping and the Chinese Communist Party to
be narco-terrorists, they're the ones who are overseeing massive
fentanyl production, do you think the current authorizations
for military force would you would be inclined the same way you're
inclined in this case to say that strikes against Beijing on
that basis and of the abduction of Xi Jinping hypothetical would
be legal, yes or no? I think legal, yeah. I'm inclined to believe
it's legal.
I'm going to
answer, but then you have to give me time to elaborate, right?
Um I do think the president has broad authority. I mean, this
is the commander-in-chief. President has broad authority to do
some pretty permanent some pretty crazy [__] Um you
know, we This was a conversation that came up back in um
I'm I'm going to pull out some alcohol and we'll see if we can
um We'll see if we can boost through this Willy Mac video and
and still correct and be more accurate in information than he
is as a like in a researched scripted
video, okay? We'll start now. I'm going to start right now and
we'll see how it goes, okay? in the Supreme Court case regarding
the Supreme Court case regarding presidential immunity, right?
I think the president has a tremendous amount of authority and
tremendous amount of ability to do things that when you start
stress testing specific analogies might seem crazy. Like holy
[__] president can just fire a nuke at Beijing. This
can happen. The president has the authority I'm drinking. None
of you drink. All of you need to be sober so you can witness
it. Okay, I need you all sober. I'll I'm the only one who's going
to have a drink. I Alcohol's bad for you. Don't drink. Actually,
yeah, the commander-in-chief has The question is whether Congress
gave that authority. Did Congress give the authority for Trump
to call China Make the booze a do no goal. I thought about it.
I I feel like at this point the Willy Mac video is going to have
to be the do no goal, so and launch attacks at China. That's
the question.
If I'm remembering correctly, I believe the standing order 2003
authorization gives the president the ability to use the military
to engage in I think they they can deploy any country Hold on.
They can deploy any country and they have to remove without congressional
approval, they have to remove within like 30 days, 60 days, something
along those lines. You can The president can unilaterally invade
a country, in fact. And if the Congress steps like then they
have to pull back if Congress doesn't get on board with it and
doesn't declare war. But yeah, the president can unilaterally
declare war
Can Can you think of a single use of military force by the military
under the purported rationale of drug enforcement that on your
view would be illegal? Can you think of any even hypothetical
act by the military against foreign countries that you think
would be illegal under the current congressional
Can you even come up with one? Um
I mean, it it
Just start it like nuking Beijing right
Why don't just start there? I'm pretty sure nuking Beijing with
no congressional authority would be a thing. Preemptively nuking
Beijing, preemptively nuking every missile facility in China.
So, if the legal thing I can think about would be if the president
if the president
um I'll I'll also go back and read the 2003 authorization. I
don't like I said, if it's on a recognized state actor. Now,
your point is going to be well, the US can just say well, we
don't recognize you as a valid state Right. Right. Is there any
I'm trying to think of any hypothetical in which the president
an actor from a state as a
does an action that you would say is
against a foreign state. I think it can be found I think it could
be found to be illegal if there's no good faith reason to believe
Okay, so yeah, hold on. Hold on. I'm giving you my view. I don't
I think it could be determined to be legal. I would think it'd
be legal if there's no good faith rationale to believe that this
is like some kind of narco-terrorist and that it actually is
legitimate state actor. So, to me the legality of it actually
comes down to the legitimacy of Maduro as a president. Well,
no, it would come down to whether or not Trump is acting in good
faith in how he's engaging with Maduro and in his
Uh we just need to judge Trump's mindset or mindset, okay? His
mind state. That's all we have to do, guys. We just have to know
his mind state. We just have to judge him. Surely there can't
be anything wrong there. Surely there's not a whole thing where
people actually know can like basically point to evidence of
his mind state, show that he was acting in bad faith, and then
everybody just didn't care and still supported him anyway, right?
Surely Surely we should just do this test again. It'll work this
I'll just give you my problem with that. If Congress has made
a system, a structure that is so permissive so as for us to have
to struggle to come up with a hypothetical where we could imagine
some
you know, illegal conduct with respect to military action, then
we have a non-delegation problem. Congress cannot delegate its
war power-making authority to that level of substance where it
just says, you know what? The president can do The president
can do whatever he wants to do and in order for us to in order
in order for us to take that away, there needs to be some additional
affirmative step by Congress. No, you would not grant this in
any other constitutional context. If you said, well, Congress
the president shall have our interstate
legislative authority and he can decide what he wants. You would
say, of course not. That's insane. If you Congress said, okay,
the president can set whatever the tax rate that he wants, you
would say, of course not. If Congress said, we we grant all appropriation
authority to the president as long as he does it in good faith,
then you would say, of course that's nonsense. Congress can't
do that. So, don't we have a humongous non-delegation
You just need to identify what's dishonest. I'll answer it.
So, what you did is you smuggled an entire argument into a menu.
So, Congress gave a menu to the president and said, here's a
list you can pick from. We're preemptively saying we know it's
a busy thing being the commander-in-chief. We don't want to have
our approval hold you up if something's important. Here's an
appetizer list for war and then if you need major war, come back.
This is roughly how Iraq went, if I understand correctly. We
started off saying, "Oh, we're just doing a little thing." Nonetheless,
Congress is not de facto, and this is your dishonesty, relinquishing
all of the war powers. They're giving a limited availability
on it, and that's the definition >> So that's what I'm
asking. What Give me an example of a military No Give me an example
of a military action taken by the administration that you would
call illegal. Hypothetical one. What would you say, "Oh yeah,
that's illegal."
Well, I'll I'll I'm going to try to answer the question, but
it might not sound like an answer up front. It'll be brief. You
might not be used to this. So, if Congress says we can declare
war forever, imagine a 10-year war, but they only give the president
60 days of a tiny sliver, or even let's even say it was the full
full full gambit of the
as the
full gambit, eh? Pretty sure it's gamut, right? Is it not
The full gamut. calendar goes, Congress is retaining the overwhelming
majority of the war powers overseeing. Thus, they're retaining
control of it. Like, they gave him a a box to live in. What part
of that do you find so so all-encompassing? That's a question.
That's not an answer to what I asked you. Do you remember what
I asked you? I can ask you again. Uh it's not two M's and an
I. It's It's I think it's gamut like this. Pretty
A complete range or scope of something. The gamut.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Woah. Woah.
Go for it. I I appreciate I'll beg you to let me speak. >> First,
can you just answer Do you remember what I asked you?
Is that the only thing you have a problem with? Honestly, they're
just taking so long to specify questions. It's not like bad argumentation.
It's good argumentation. It's not really good reaction content
when they're being like extremely pedantic with the things they're
saying. I understand why it's important to make your arguments.
It's just not the best content sometimes. Especially when I don't
think these guys are going to actually take it seriously or listen
anyway.
I lose track of the way you make your >> [__]
listen when I ask a question? And if I don't
Pisco says the same thing. I'm like, "They're not going to listen
anyway." So you're taking all this time to iron out the exactly
what you're saying, and they're literally not paying attention.
So So like you're They're literally not paying attention. You're
just wasting all of this time. It's But I don't know. There's
no fix. You still have to do it this way, I guess. >> So
So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So
So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So So Or can
you make up a hypothetical? And I gave you a hypothetical about
a war. Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait So a 10-year hypothetical
10-year war a hypothetical a hypothetical 10-year war. So So
assume So that's like three character attacks from this guy on
to Pisco for Pisco's one back. I do think um or like personal
attacks. I do think eventually Pisco's going to start launching
more bombs, >> president says, as he's doing now, or as
uh is being suggested he could do under the current legal theories,
that under the AUMF, we have This is part of a I believe this
guy said that Congress might give like approval for something,
as in like in an emergency situation, you could do up to this
line. He said hypothetically that could be a So like you could
start with a small thing and work your way up, I guess, but he
didn't even flesh it out to the point where this is what he thinks
happened here. He just gave like a The hypothetical was, hypothetically
Congress could like pre-authorize some level of action, but not
all of it. And then they'd have to make a determination later.
>> our extended fight against terrorism. Cuz that is the
argument. Yeah. I I feel like you just have a easy line of saying
nuking. If If Pisco's just trying to get like anything cuz Pisco
They don't want to say that cuz Pisco's clearly arguing about
how you can erode this into anything being legal,
But it's like nuking would be the one you just start with like
the strongest >> is they're narco-terrorists, and this
is a greater than 10 years. You agree AUMF is greater than 10
years? Agreed? Yes or Well, hold up. Hold up. Was the AUMF started
Just answer the question. Was the AUMF passed more than 10 years
ago?
What Sweet [__] is that answer to the
Yes, that was That was 2001. That was in 2001. I I was I was
mixing More than 20 years ago. It's more than 10 years ago. It's
more than 20 years ago. It's somewhere. Come on. There's a 1973
There's a 1973 uh War Powers Act that specifically gives the
president the right to engage the armed forces in a country,
but they have to pull out uh without uh congressional approval.
They have to pull it out within um certain amount of days. It's
like 60 days. So So So So So So Yeah, so that's 1973. Now, that
was expanded in the 2001 Authorization for Use of Force. Um and
and that also kind of gives the president the discretion to choose
who they believe is related to like terrorist organizations that
are related to uh the attack on 9/11, which has been interpreted
pretty far broadly. Um but it seems like under either of these
authorizations AUMF, you think? Let's deal with both. Well, let's
let's go in chronologically then. So, uh right here, the War
Powers Resolution requires president to notify Congress within
48 hours of committing armed forces to military action.
Are they Holy [__] They just looked at the panel.
Are they all auditioning to be the next Unabomber? There's so
much Unkempt Hero on the screen.
Um yeah, they're libertarians. That's literally their hero. They're
just all trying to look like their Jesus. Yes. Which he did.
>> Yes. Um from remaining for more than 60 days, with a
further 30-day withdrawal period. Um I guess my first question
for you is, why would Congress authorize the president to deploy
troops and notify them within 48 hours after he deployed troops?
So it um Where's the
with three billion Read Read Read the provision of the War Powers
Act that actually authorizes it.
Now, give me a second.
And while he's going while he's looking for that, let me read
a few more super chats to make a little money here. Odashara
for $5 says, "Maduro gone, good. Maduro being gone because of
big oil, bad." Fair fair pick. $5 for Marlo
That person is a total schizophrenic, okay? Odashara, total schizophrenic.
>> Pisco, I love you, dude, but all this ad hom just makes
you sound like you're not bright enough to be a drunk I I don't
give a [__]
Oh, dude, are people comparing about the ad homs at this point?
Like the The drunk thing was funny, although it is mean to Gibbs.
It is funny content, okay? It's better
I'm sorry. It's just It's better content. That's what you guys
say, you [__] So So all all the people in the chat
who are saying, "Oh my god, just be nicer. Just be nicer." If
you don't They will go off to the races talk about random [__]
You want me on that wall. You need me on that [__]
Let me Let me Let me Let me Let me Let me Let me finish my response.
I have super chat. I have super chat real quick. I just want
to say I have super chat. Can we be fair? Like you know what?
I admit the ad homs have come from bro show. I just you know
Pisco, you should probably find a All right, don't go down the
roast battle. You'll lose that one. You might win the law battle,
you're not going to win the roast battle. Okay. Regardless, $20
from cameraman. They say in regards to Panama, that was after
months of run-up and vocal demands. Though no legislative action
by a Democratic Congress for action. We
We didn't eat I mean, that's probably why they were doing this
whole thing in the run-up with the boat with the boats and declaring
them a cartel, putting the bounties out. I think all of that
is a like legal It's setting yourself up for some legal like
uh what would you say? Plausible deniability once you're down
the road a little more. military metal to take him into custody.
This Panama 2.0 sucks. So, a couple more uh differences just
because I I researched this a little bit. In Noriega, Panama
declared a state of war between the US and Panama before we went
in. Did we Did we declare war? Did we declare war on Panama?
No, they did. Okay, well, I don't care what they're what they
did.
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait. Do not attach
lactoid to DGG. I'm warning you guys right now. That's not who
lactoid is.
Lactoid is not like a DGG or that's not something that's happening.
Hold on. If If you guys are Don't do that. It's the wrong narrative
you come out of this with, okay? >> I'm I'm just The differences
between Venezuela and Panama No, that's relevant. That's relevant
to our law, right? What we're waiting for is uh under the War
Powers Act, where Congress has authorized any particular
Yeah, so go ahead and read your thing. I'll read the rest of
super chats later, but go ahead. >> Sure. So, uh when I
This is the section that I believe is relevant. Provides that
in the absence of congressional Can you just name the section
title?
The The title by the section. Um
HJ Resolution 542 No no no no no no no no The section of the
act of the War Powers Act. Which section are you reading? There's
section one, uh section two. There's you know, the title above
it. Consultation, reporting, congressional action. I was looking
at You know, I was looking at the summary on the Congress page.
So, give me a second to find the actual full Yeah, we want the
the part of the law itself that authorizes the president to take
any
Okay, well, let me read these other super chats while we wait
then.
$2 from No no no no no. I'm just talking about Achilles. I'm
I'm talking about like the the Okay. Yeah, so give me give me
the Give me the section So So So So 50 US Code Chapter 33, War
Powers Resolution, Section 1543A.
Um Section A, in general, not later than 48 hours after any incident
in which the US armed forces are involved in an attack or hostilities,
whether in an offensive or defensive capacity, the president
shall transmit to the Congressional Defense Committees, Committee
on Foreign Relations of the Senate, and the Committee on Foreign
Affairs of the House of Representatives a report on the incident,
unless the president otherwise reports the incident within 48
hours pursuant to Section 1543 of this title, or has determined
prior to the incident, and so reported pursuant to Section 1549
of this title, that the US United States armed forces involved
in the incident would be operating under specific statutory authority
within the meaning of Section 1544B of this title. So, here's
the question. Is that Is that provision of law that you just
read a reporting requirement for the president, or is that authorization
to take particular action?
Well, I think it No, I think it removes the argument that he
needed to consult Congress before we launched the launched the
attack to get Maduro. So So we're not saying we're not saying
we're not saying we're not saying we're not saying we're not
saying we're not >> but it's conditional. Wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait Are you denying that uh one of
the main like legal gripes I mean, not you, but one of the main
legal gripes that I've been hearing is that um he should have
consulted Congress first
So yes, people are making the policy argument that he should
have consulted with Congress. But legally, he doesn't
I think most people are making the legal argument that he legally
had to inform
I think most people are saying it's illegal because he didn't
have congressional approval in any way.
And this is very different, right? Wait. Also, for the reporting
thing, does he have to do that before or after? I didn't even
I swear to God I like didn't pay attention to what Lactoid was
saying when he was reading. It started to muddy together. So
legally he's allowed to do that but the question isn't But before
before he goes sorry sorry Sorry Lactoid, I'm not going to get
[__] distracted. The question isn't pursuant to the
reporting require or sorry to the whatever the policy arguments
made by Democrats and people who are on Twitter, what do they
say? The question is under the War Powers Act, where does it
authorize particular military action? Or is the War Powers Act
better read as a restriction on the president's authority and
providing specific reporting requirements? Which is the better
interpretation? That the War Powers Act is a a grant of a 60-day
fun zone anytime you want to do anything you want or that the
War Powers Act is restraining control and putting reporting requirements
in place?
Sure, it's restricting the president's war powers. It does. But
it specifically allows the president to commit US forces without
congressional Hold on. Hold on. to without congressional authorization
as long as it's reported Where does it authorize that? Wait,
where does it authorize it? Hey hey hey Stop talking for a second,
okay? You just let me finish. Um So within we can commit troops
and then has it without congressional knowledge, without letting
them know, can just do it.
Uh I do think hold on. I I mean I have to go read it myself now.
But I do think if it's basically saying that you know, within
48 hours if it if it without specifying just says you have to
let us know that this happened within 48 hours and then you have
like 60 days based on congressional approval
like based on whether or not you you get congressional approval
to pull out. Like if you don't get full scale congressional approval
you have 60 days. If that's what it says then I'm going to say
that that
is more or less agreeing or or there is the understanding that
you're allowed to do that. That it does it it doesn't authorize
you but it is implying that you were previously authorized.
Otherwise, why would any of those words be required? You just
wait for the congressional authorization.
Right? Am I crazy here? I feel like that's got to be the case.
That if if this thing even exists the reason it exists is because
you didn't need the congressional approval in the first
If you required the congressional approval, none of this would
exist. Right? And then within 48 hours he has to give them That's
what it requires. It requires reporting. It doesn't authorize
an underlying act. It doesn't it doesn't He's go He's go He's
go He's go He's go He's go. Um within 40 hours I have to notify
Congress. So you say it's a policy argument. I that's not how
I No, but I'm not I'm not I'm not talking about it. I'm not talking
I'm not I'm not No, I'm talking about a
This is very frustrating when you're debating somebody and they're
like well, I understand what you're saying but other people say
the thing that I actually want to argue with cuz it's
I understand I know what you're saying, but other people have
made an argument that's like way easier for me to make fun of
and way easier for me to go So I think I want to go after that
argument. Could you just give me some room to go It's like, no,
shut up. I'm not making that argument. Argue with >> Wait
wait wait wait wait Lactoid Lactoid Lactoid stop. Hold on. Just
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Both of you Both of you Both Both
of you Both of you Both of you Both of you
I'm going to finish up my Let Lactoid finish his point. Yeah,
Pisco you respond. Lactoid go ahead. Right. Uh it also puts the
a restriction that you can commit forces within if you commit
for you cannot commit forces for longer than 60 days without
congressional approval. And then a 30-day extension beyond that
from Congress. And so uh the question is did uh does the president
have to even consult with Congress beforehand? I heard you uh
make the argument that they had to that he had to earlier when
you were comparing it to China when you compare it to other uh
countries get >> Oh my I'm guessing sorry, I'm guessing
Missy that this is very much like many other powers of the president.
That essentially it's like sort of assumed by a lot of the founding
documents, the founders in general, that the American people
will elect somebody of high moral character, a very like conscientious
and good person that will respect the powers of the office and
not try to expand them
I think there's a lot of assumptions like that that underlie
the presidency that the American people will not elect a total
[__]
right? Somebody who doesn't care, has no respect for the power
of the office, no respect for like the ex like the normalized
limits of the office. I think there's a ton of stuff that exists
in terms of presidential power that are like there will be, you
know learned men here who respect the office, who respect everything
that's a part of it, right? It's like I'm pretty sure that's
a an assumption of a whole bunch of things the president can
technically do or that it's not legally specified.
So it's probably one of those things where like, yeah, technically
you can't nuke a country, but they didn't think you'd need to
like list something out where it's like if you have the potential
to eliminate an entire country, you can't just do that without
congressional
Isn't Congress supposed to hold the president accountable? Well,
it does sound like accountable. Like I don't think anybody doubts
if it were straight up illegal, if you weren't allowed to do
then why would the president even have like the nuclear codes?
Why wouldn't Congress be endowed somehow with the nuclear codes?
Right? Why would the president even have them? Why would the
nuclear football follow the president around?
It's like the president technically probably does have the power
and then Congress can hold him accountable if he uses that power
in bad faith.
But I would imagine that the actual authority to do these things
does lie with the president. Because again I believe the founders
basically assumed that the the presidents of the United States
would mostly be people like George Washington, Thomas Jefferson
right? They would be, you know, smart people who understood that
they were going to set precedents in the future. Didn't you liar?
When did I say that that was No, I never made an assertion that
was hypothetical back to you. You [__] liar. I said
I said I I I said I heard it. I also said if you're not making
that argument, fine. Maybe I misunderstood. Um but of course
charity is just not a concept to you. Um >> wait no no
no you didn't you didn't hear No no no no no stop stop Hey hey
no Pisco Pisco you're an [__] and you're going to
let me finish a sentence. This is such a you're a liar. Then
you You're a [__] I'm so sorry. No no you you You
Hold on. I said you're an [__] I didn't say you're
in bad faith. Sorry, you are accusing me of not having charity.
Charity lacking charity and and doing and understanding interpreting
you I'm talking about charity. Charity charity charity Yeah yeah
yeah Wait wait I'm talking about charity Wait wait wait stop
stop
This is probably too pedantic to argue on but I get it. Pisco
Pisco wants to exert his will on these people. >> Wait
no no no no we all Pisco's treating Pisco's treating Lactoid
like those pirates treated Admiral Gibbs' mom, okay? But we are
You just said I didn't accuse you of bad faith and I said uh
and you just said that I wasn't being charitable. Isn't interpreting
someone uncharitable bad faith? Yes or no? So interpreting somebody
uncharitable is bad Yes yes So you are accusing me of bad faith,
right? Wait, so Lactoid you are accusing me of bad faith. The
specific thing the specific thing I'm talking about when it comes
to lack of charity here is first of all you're >> bad faith
or are you accusing me of bad faith? which you constantly which
you constantly do. You're like now now I think you're acting
in bad faith actually. Now the fact that you're constantly interrupting
me. I do think you're acting in bad faith right now. I think
that often times in conversations you can like just don't have
the charity to even listen to other people's arguments. And then
and then you're going to [__] that other people don't
Uh Lactoid, this is the one thing I've noticed that Lactoid is
very good at. Lactoid is very good at like rage baiting and then
being calm. He's like very very very good at it most of the time.
He'll he knows exactly how annoyed all of the people who are
like left leaning, he knows how annoyed they get when you're
like saying calmly like the things you think in terms of you're
like a right winger, you're just calmly saying your beliefs.
He knows that that can piss people off and he's very good at
just remaining calm and He's the He's the guy who's not bothered
>> of your arguments, right? Because of course, you know,
you just you don't let me finish a sentence. Um So don't don't
tell me what to do. Don't tell me what to do. I'm telling I'm
going to beat I I I I I can I can write about this for the next
30 minutes if I want to, right? No no no no no no no no no The
only person The only person who has the ability to stop me is
He is the only person that has the ability to stop me.
Uh-oh. Reuben Reuben donated $3. I'm pretty sure it's pronounced
pay-door-on-tic but I could be wrong.
Pedantic, they're getting very pedantic. That's true. Thank you
very much Reuben
Nick Lee propaganda happening in real >> stop you if it
gets boring to me, but go ahead. Be brief. Sure. Uh so you sure
I'm going to ask So I'm going to ask Pisco to listen to me um
as opposed to interrupting me. So um if we're talking about it
okay, so he doesn't have to let Congress know uh before he does
it. So whatever like legal
theory about Um I don't mind Pisco being like rude here. I don't
I don't mind it.
I think he's trying to figure out where
he's trying to figure out where the lines are on being rude like
this. There are lines though and I do think he actually crosses
the lines like of what would be most effective, but you don't
really figure that out unless you're willing to cross some lines.
Okay? If you're trying to figure out how to do something that
you've never done before
the best way to figure it out is to [__] it up in
the extreme.
Okay? But if you if you just tow up to the line, that's a very
slow way of learning. The best way to learn something new, to
figure out how to do something new, Pisco being like super rude
to people on stream. This it's not entirely new cuz he used to
do this to Rage Popal all the time, but like that kind of thing,
you should you should go over the line instead of just like trying
to tow up to the line. You'll never figure out where the line
is unless you're willing to just like leap across it.
So I I don't mind this as long as he understands that it could
go too far, he could end up like ruining some bridges with people
if he does it too much. But I don't think he really cares here.
I do think Lactoid's like
amongst the right wingers who would actually argue with Pisco
Lactoid's probably the best faith one.
Like pretty easily. Like way more way more good faith than Rob
Noer, way more good faith than most people cuz he spends all
of his time arguing with DGGers, right? Like if I remember correctly,
he's the guy who's always in the DGG or politics or Wick server
arguing with people about whatever,
I think that's like who he is. So he's normally arguing with
liberals, he'll normally be a lot more charitable than to liberals.
More good faith than Connor? Yeah, I think so. Although Connor's
not necessarily bad faith. No. No, Connor's probably too good
faith for his own arguments to be honest. About that being incorrect
I think is is obviously untrue. Um the question of okay, does
he have Article 2 authority to initiate these strikes in the
first place? Um like I'm going to repeat what I said before because,
you know, maybe Pesco didn't hear me. I don't know for sure.
I'm leaning towards yes just given historically US actions regarding
um, you know, presidential actions on air strikes on terrorists,
on narco-terrorists. Um, I I I haven't seen any kind of strong
legal authority demonstrating the president has broken the law
here. If this happens to shift, if it the you know, Supreme Court
actually looks at this and say it says actually, the president
has been they've been doing this, uh, they have been violating
they're going beyond the scope of Article 2 authority, um, then
then sure, then that would be illegal. Uh, it's what it seems
like has been happening and if you want to roll back the tape
and look at my position from the my position from the very beginning
is I have not taken a ultra strong stance that of course the
president is justi- Ryan Malali is much better is much smarter
than Lactoid. Really?
I don't know anything about Ryan. I I Sorry, I say really. I
think Ryan asked me to debate once and I just didn't I don't
even remember I think I was busy.